en ces temps de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
des entreprises ont choisi de bonifier
l'offre alimentaire qu'elle propose à
leurs équipes on se demande si cette
stratégie est efficace pour attirer et
garder les employés
je mange le bol du jour
avec des légumes et du bœuf du riz avec
plein de légumes des crevettes
comme à chaque jour c'est toujours
excellent
et de ses capitales ça se peut
à 3h tous les jours c'est vraiment la
qualité là c'est très bistrot là on est
pourtant ici aussi dans une cafétéria
avec une tombée de tomate une salade de
chou-fleur ok la petite tomate peut
aller sous le veau des herbes fraîches
l'entreprise créative Sylvie de Montréal
offre gratuitement le déjeuner et les
collations à ses employés en plus de
subventionner le repas du midi un repas
complet 8 dollars ici chez Sylvie on
sort une formule 3 services donc on a un
entré le plat et le dessert moi ce qui
est plaisant c'est que toutes les odeurs
se distribuent dans le lobby là-bas et
monte aux étages fait que si on cuit du
bacon ou quelque chose qui sent bon les
employés le sont pressés de venir manger
loin bon appétit prochain merci au début
on a des constamment des gens qui est
rentré
pour faciliter le retour en présentiel
ou pour attirer de nouveaux employés les
riches entreprises de technologie et de
communication mis sur la qualité de la
nourriture au bouleau
les entreprises y trouvent leur compte
pour l'employeur c'est quoi l'intérêt
parce que ça coûte cher à ce que vous
offrez
nous on travaille on a la chance de
travailler en ce moment avec la table
des chefs qui est un OSB à
extraordinaire si on a une belle
association avec eux depuis peu on le
dit ça fait peut-être un an un an et
demi ça fait partie de notre culture ça
fait partie d'une des raisons pourquoi
je pense nos employés aiment ça ici
reste chez nous et même viennent c'est
un élément de voir ses employés là
revenir et de se regrouper ici autour
d'un repas
au bureau morialet de la firme de
logiciel Lightspeed on va même jusqu'à
offrir tous les repas et collations
gratuitement
Diane Gabriel Tremblay n'observe pas de
tendance quand à cette idée d'utiliser
la nourriture comme stratégie pour
recruter mais elle trouve l'idée
inspirant et les gens de ressources
humaines d'ailleurs médecin de l'avant
maintenant comme un des aspects qui peut
attirer la méthode et la retenir aussi
parce que c'est bien de la faire venir
mais il faut aussi la conserver vous
avez l'impression que vous êtes même
capable d'attirer des gens par la
nourrice
notre équipe de recrutement pourrait
vous le dire en fait ça fait partie des
bénéfices et des avantages de travailler
chez Sylvie paraissent Balto Thompson
[Musique]
avec eux c'est mon collègue tout autant
puis le matin c'est bon matin c'est
super bon hello
bon appétit c'était bien sûr qu'on peut
se faire le café on peut tous faire chez
soi mais au fond l'idée c'est que
l'alimentation c'est un lieu c'est un
moment de plaisir d'échange on constate
que pour attirer les gens pour que les
gens reviennent les gestionnaires sont à
la recherche justement d'idées et de
fait l'alimentation en fait partie même
dans le domaine de l'éducation la
nourriture sert d'être au collège André
Gresset à Montréal les employés et les
étudiants sont aussi choyés
pour nous c'est un facteur qui est
important le milieu de l'éducation c'est
un milieu qu'on dit humain donc nous
sommes en mesure d'offrir des bons
repères les gens se rassemblent
également c'est un marque de
reconnaissance aussi d'offrir aux
employés que ce soit des repas que ce
soit des certaines commodités de
nourriture mais c'est un élément qu'on
considère important et ça permet de
valoriser le personnel
oui c'est ça ça a été cueilli l'un
derrière on est aujourd'hui on est les
tomates c'est ça puis là on est en fait
saison donc on a épuisé on a passé des
courgettes qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire avec ça aujourd'hui je vais faire
une salade de tomates boccacini basilic
le bien simple pour le comptoir des
sandwichs la chef Marie-Josée et son
équipe sont responsables de régaler tout
le monde chaque midi avec des produits
plus que frais pour le bonheur du
personnel des étudiants et du directeur
[Musique]
en milieu scolaire et en milieu
corporatif on n'a pas beaucoup de
clients on choisit nos clients très
ciblés pour axer sur une qualité repas
il nous aide au point de vue financier
soit en subventionnant à 100% ou soit
ici comme le collège Jean de grassets en
sauvant sur le loyer et en disant eux
ils veulent absolument une qualité dans
l'assiette et un rapport qualité prix ça
nous permet de rendre les prix plus
accessibles à l'élève autant aux
employés le fait de travailler avec une
petite entreprise permet beaucoup plus
de flexibilité donc on s'est entendu sur
les valeurs communes donc qualité de
service qualité de la nourriture des
aliments québécois le volet toute
environnemental diminution de tout ce
qui est plastique
retrait de tout ce qui est vaisselle
jetable mais ce sont tous des enjeux
auxquels nous croyons
un bistro pour prolonger les heures
d'ouverture un potager qui sert aux
employés une bière brassée avec le haut
blanc qui pose sur le terrain la
nourriture au collège est au centre des
priorités ça peut être le petit plus qui
va permettre à une organisation de
différencier des autres en offrant comme
ça des repas ou simplement des cafés des
fruits et des viennoiseries
éventuellement
les gens se servent comme si c'est à la
maison mais le but c'est qu'il arrive
plutôt au bureau qui mange au bureau et
qui travaille au bureau voilà
moins cher manger à la maison qu'une
entreprise subventionnée pour les
employeurs il y a une raison aussi dire
à mes employés vont se regrouper ils
mangent à la même table un sentiment
d'appartenance Manger Santé manger
ensemble un gros plus donc d'espace
d'argent ou même d'intérêt encore peu
d'entreprises mais de plus en plus
d'employeurs adhèrent à cette nouvelle
vision des conditions de travail les PME
c'est probablement pour elle que c'est
le plus difficile par contre je pense au
PME en région on entend dire bon là
c'est le temps des récoltes là à
l'automne donc on peut imaginer qu'il y
a une association entre une PME et des
agriculteurs locaux qui ont des produits
toutes les organisations pourraient sans
doute trouver une idée qui soit pas
nécessairement aussi coûteuse que ce
qu'on retrouve là dans multimédia et
jeux vidéo